hello everybody and welcome to part 11
of let's play pin number the Black
Plague all right we last left off
Clarence played a stupid oh look at this
Oh Lee oh I'm mega awesome on ultra mega
combo three exact day oh yeah
Oh what do I do Lloyd Oh lighter I got a
lot ah don't kill me
Oh No okay feel up oh there we go [ __ ] -
like that oh ah I know
ah I got a spray paint oh yeah my
flamethrower that's right food ah yeah
clunk go go go go go go go oh yeah go
team go
alright on the condom best this charade
Billy lasted all your mind like a garish
wall paint Billy he wanted to die and
him oh yeah yeah he's
oh no don't get rid of Billy I my only
friend all right
anyway I got warmed up I'm all good
got a dirty old cloth cuz I'm a
kleptomaniac all right what's over here
what's over here nothing absolutely
nothing squid-diddly do we did Lee do I
don't know
Oh what's this
Oh explosives oh I finally finally I get
to blow something up all finally all
I've been waiting for this all the whole
time
Oh been waiting for this well I mean I
blew something up into overture but I
mean now I can never mind I'm gonna blow
something up that's all that matters
oh I can take this over there no I can't
nevermind
okay um dirty old cloth off Franco put
it and oh I know Oh
alcohol oh yeah oh yeah okay all right
all right here we go
I'm so smart so smart
oh yeah all right light is up Oh get
away oh oh oh
kaboom
oh yeah yeah I'm a Belle I'm a here oh
yeah
ah yeah loading come on load faster I
got a beast killer computer there we go
show on dueling Oh your voice is so
annoying am so in distress kill the bad
guys
pure infection uh-huh the world uh-huh
success nil I like those odds
survival well you got Oh Clarence a your
horde actions hurt you so much chances
of you buttering things up wrong almost
spec oh shut up you okay the four-year
before you are four yah all right I came
in number one right Girish
okay - research facility I think that's
where she is some of its at her first oh
yeah okay all right here we go
this dark humming get some batteries for
my ten-second flashlight uh-huh hello
you turning up here is probably oh yeah
happened he's not the first best I'm
reserving first place but when we get
out oh yeah we say I'm not big-headed
enough to think you came all the way
here just to rescue ma but I did good
buying though I think I've worked out
how to disinfect you ah hot hot you
probably saw this coming uh-huh it's not
quite as similar guys cut off my foot
I had to engage the failsafe on the
research rooms to seal myself in here
uh-huh
that means we need a keycard to get me
out right one of us now one of the
infected one Oh bring it on
oh good rip them up far away wait when
yeah look I I need you oh yeah well uh
yeah I'll give you the biggest ho ho ho
oh yeah a broad a typical circumstances
uh-huh fate has anything to do with this
faith is merely the war cry of those do
scared to think I'm shut out I'm gonna
rescue her I'm gonna get the biggest hug
of my life oh yeah all right okay
oh let's figure this out Oh examination
area right there there's rooms scattered
all over the place oh god that's a lot
of rooms that I got a good Oh if I miss
one thing from any room I'm gonna be
running circles forever so let's make
sure I get everything okay be four or
five sixes just down here okay
ah ah that's boarded up okay hopefully
most of them are either don't budge or
are completely boarded up okay all right
okay let's go to three three sounds good
just down this way take a right left
left
okay right left and a left
okay yep all right um so great Comair
guy where's this suppose it infected
nowhere that's right
all right let's see uh oh yeah what's
this nitrogen yeah he's a nitrogen gas
nitrogen is isn't in a solid form unless
it's very very cold nitrogen oxide maybe
there's a gas ah who knows nope nothing
oops
yeah yeah oh no I should stop touching
them then but I won't babe who's in here
Oh nobody that's right gimme all right
ha ha ha ah yeah nothing
batteries um all right what's in here
aah aah get out of the way me Oh what's
this
Wow a coin again you look flammable
anything up there oh yeah oh yeah I'm so
ingenuitive I always look on the top
shelf iodine iodine let's see hoof
Peterloo butter do
nope nah ninguna nothing nothing ah no
it's the only other door in here bad you
with it no that shirt doesn't pick up
you ah here's chair chair but come on
coop I saw you move Boop all right
nothing huh get held up by Oh Oh what's
this Oh get out of here
I win oh I'm breaking the game I'm so
breaking the game here oh come on oh
yeah
no oh I had it I had it chair a one more
time chair Boop bah ah now I really got
stuck didn't I baby make me oh oh yeah
Oh get out of here
oh I win I win oh no one more one more
Oh chair oh oh come on
ah no I had it I almost broke the game
aah no no aah
damn
all right fine I'll do it your way seem
a bit out of place well let's move it
then all yeah oh yeah let's see what's
in here
blood it doesn't scare me oh we're
taking me two seconds to go this way oh
no oh no no oh no oh no oh no I broke
the game I broke it I broke it I broke
it
I'm so screwed I can't get back in oh
I'm so screwed I'm screwed
I totally just broke the game guys I'm
sorry about that
that's are anything behind here Oh
another one behind the milk jugs all
these drugs there's bound to be a big
old needle at the end of this sure is
I'd be enough to put any man on uh-huh
you don't want to catch anything one
virus is enough for any portion of I'll
take ten bars I could bring it on nope
what if I gotta inject I don't know I
don't know I don't know oh what's this
oh oh that's oh good huh for a second
there I thought that was weird
oh man II look at you oh you're so ugly
and then we get to hack off something
shut up I'm thinking straight you're the
one infected with a virus boop boop boop
boop boop
all right did you start dumping things
in oh yeah just throw em in willy-nilly
gone bingo
all right enough primitive
makes you're not complete why did I miss
I miss something good night Oh what did
I miss
let's see probable entry point in the
spy okay sounds good to me
alright nothing and everything here I'm
on the barrels oh no oh no alright trash
bag behind nothing oh man this is so bad
oh this is bad
all of that is bad oh like you be
anything nothing oh god I broke the game
oh I broke it I broke the game
oh I can't get out can i oh I'm so
screwed give me a barrel all barrel
please please barrel oh yeah oh yeah get
straight up straight up gangsta
I know straight up ah ah get straight
okay I know don't even ah I'm gonna kill
someone get stop I hate you oh there we
go
finally oh my god oh I'm cool I'm cool
alright let's see did I miss any
chemicals
anything anything at all anything all
right all right I got a posit
let me just touch the old save point
okay all right thank you so much for
watching guys and I will see you guys in
part 12 of let's play penumbra the Black
Plague bye bye